- Oh, don't come and sneak up on me!
Don't sneak up!
(upbeat music)
Hey tasty, it's me, Danny Trejo
and as you can probably guess
one of my favorite things
to do is to cook tacos.
Today, I'm going to show you
three of my favorite recipes.
First up, is a quick and
delicious 10-minute Shrimp Taco.
Next is a savory 1-hour
Fried Chicken Taco.
And if you really wanna impress,
I'm going to show you a Brisket Taco
that takes a full day to make.
Now let's get cooking!
Okay first up is our Shrimp Diablo Taco.
Now, the machete is not
needed for this recipe.
Start with our roasted
garlic, chipotle sauce,
our olive oil, garlic powder, salt, honey,
like the way I did that, it was cool.
And then our lemon juice.
All these go into the blender
to make our Diablo sauce.
(blender whirring)
You know I used a blender
in a movie before,
you make people tell you something.
Ooh!
Mix it well.
Now we've got a bowl of shrimp
mixed very very well with our Diablo sauce
this is a quick marinade,
and then we're going to grill it.
We got our pan nice and hot.
Now an old trick that I learned
was putting oil on one side
and just doing this,
that way it's evenly spread.
Oh yeah!
Two to three minutes,
flip it over
and the nice thing about shrimp
is that it cooks fast and
it's absolutely delicious
especially with the Diablo sauce.
That's the kicker.
Okay now these start to
look nice, good and crispy,
smell absolutely delicious.
Please sir, may I have another?
Okay now, we're almost done
with the Shrimp Diablo.
Get our tortillas that
you've put in the oven
wrapped in tinfoil for about five minutes.
What I always like to do
is put the guacamole first
so that it'll spread on the tortilla
and then cabbage and pickled onion,
this is what we're mixing up right now.
Next are piece (indistinct) or shrimp,
never skimp on the shrimp.
Now just a little cilantro,
some people don't like cilantro.
Then of course our lime juice.
Delicious!
For a 10 minute taco, this can't be beat
and kids don't talk with your mouthful.
(upbeat music)
Up next is our Fried Chicken Taco
now that's a winner.
First step is our flour.
Pour our flour in here,
next garlic powder, onion powder,
oregano, paprika, little bit of cayenne,
of course some salt
and black pepper.
Then what we're doing is
using chicken thighs and mix
little bit with the buttermilk.
Chicken's looking good
and we're ready to move on
to our next step.
Once it gets to 350 we're ready to go.
From the buttermilk, to the flour,
make sure you mix it real good
and then shake it off,
and then just, whoa!
It's been about seven minutes
and our chicken is looking good.
You're looking for a real nice
golden brown crispy cover.
Okay now we're gonna
make our chipotle cream.
Sour cream, next is our chipotle peppers
with adobo sauce.
Salt, our lime juice.
It's my favorite part,
operating heavy machinery.
(blender whirring)
We're gonna put about a quarter cup
into our cabbage,
salt and pepper
and a little bit of
olive oil, mix this up,
oh yeah!
And really this is good just like this.
Pico de gallo was one
of my favorite sauces.
Our pico de gallo what we've got,
chips of jalapeno, red onions,
and then the tomato,
cilantro, our lemon juice,
a little salt, some olive oil.
We wanted to do a healthy taco
with a little bit of protein.
So what we did was get lettuce, cabbage,
and then we got our pico de gallo.
Let's do a little more sauce
and here is your perfect
1-hour Fried Chicken Taco.
Next is the Barbacoa Brisket Taco.
Now this was inspired by my
mom's recipe for Barbacoa.
So the first step, salt,
next sugar, next is cumin,
pepper and garlic.
Now what we do is this,
we're putting this all
over this brisket, okay?
Set this in plastic,
let it sit for approximately eight hours.
That's right, you heard it, eight hours.
Now, believe me, this
one's really worth it.
Now the key to this recipe
is the three B's,
brine, browning and braise.
Right now we are going to brown.
Neutral oil, there it is.
Ooh!
Oh yeah!
Sizzle, sizzle, sizzle,
mom, you watching?
(Danny chuckles)
All right now I'm turning
this over right now.
That's Browning.
You don't wanna get it any more than that.
Through the other side,
this is real good and brown
so here we go, put this over here,
now we get to our sauce.
First, naturally our onion,
garlic, coriander, cumin, chili powder.
We get our vinegar, bay
leaves and tomatoes.
And these, we crush up with our hand,
looking good!
Next, we got our chipotle,
this takes a little while sometimes
it is our molasses.
Last but not least
is a cup and a half of water.
Now this is packed with flavor.
We're gonna put our brisket in here.
Soaking up all 'em juices.
We're gonna cover this
and then bring this to a boil.
Okay now this is pretty well at a boil
so now what we'll do,
get this, cover it,
and we'll put the lid back on.
Put the oven at 350,
cook it for eight hours.
Just brought this out of the oven,
pulled the brisket out,
we've reduced the broth by half.
Now, at Trejo's we don't
even touch the brisket
until we can pull it apart
with just two forks like that.
Oh yeah!
Here we go.
Oh now!
Hey the brisket came out great!
Like always.
Remember, first goes the tortillas
and then goes our brisket
oh this smells delicious already.
Little bit of pico de gallo,
we've got our Cotija cheese,
and don't forget the tortilla strips.
There's no words to describe
what's going on in my mouth right now.
All right, there you have it.
Three tacos.
You've got Shrimp Diablo,
you've got Fried Chicken
and you've got the Barbacoa brisket.
If you have trouble,
it's all in the cookbook.
All of it.
Hey, thank you for watching,
get cooking
or I hope to see you at the restaurants.